if there's anything that i am
pretty confident of it's that marvel
know how to make a good
trailer they so rarely have trailers
that aren't absolute bangers
so today we are going to watch the
official doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness trailer um
obviously marvel is heading in a
direction of more and more and more
multiverse and i'm very excited about it
i feel like it's um it lets people be a
lot more creative if you're not shackled
by just one universe uh it's also you
know a lot of potential for cameos and
just a lot of unexpected stuff for the
audience i think that uh it's harder to
do if you don't have multiple universes
so
i'm gonna watch the trailer and i
believe there's also
a 30-second spot that played at the
super bowl um i've not seen any of the
super bowl commercials uh so i thought
that i would also track that down after
we finished watching this one but uh
yeah let's do the official one first
this is
two
minutes and 16 seconds and we are
watching it on the official marvel
uh youtube channel
every night
i dream the same dream
the sound design's awesome
the nightmare begins
does not look bad shirtless good to know
i did what i had to do
to protect our world
we can't control everything strange it's
their response to spider-man
you opened the doorway between universes
and we don't know who or what will walk
through it
chills wonder
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories he believed it was
dangerous
he was right
it makes me think of sentry
i'm sorry stephen
your desecration of reality
will not go unpunished this is visually
just so cool
we should tell him the truth
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
things just got out of hand
is that a different version of himself
[Music]
and become a hero
what about all the people in that bus i
do it i become the enemy
[Applause]
that doesn't seem fair
[Music]
[Applause]
that was a really good trailer
oh my god there is a lot to unpack there
i i mean visually i feel like that was
stunning like back to back
so many just like impressive vistas um
knowing that they're cg
they still look just
gorgeous like i'm so into this city
man
that looks so so so good um they
certainly didn't be putting a lot of
money into it i also just thought that
all the wonder stuff was especially
compelling i have always loved scarlet
witch but i feel like um i also really
like wanda in the mcu and i really liked
one division i am
so interested in her
darker side and her conflicts
that um
seeing little little touches of that is
especially awesome
um
this stuff
very very cool to look at just like a
lot of i mean
[Music]
a lot of impressive visuals like
stunning i mean obviously they're good
at cinematography who are we getting
they know how to shoot stuff
yeah
this i feel like i could watch this
again and break it down and talk about
who was who and
man it looks really really good um and i
also love that we kind of know now that
disney doesn't actually spoil everything
in the trailers like we know for sure
that
they don't
just outright um
put everything that's in the movie into
the trailer we often get things that are
like red herrings or tricks a lot of the
time
it's a very interesting shot
very interesting shot um
let's read some comments shall we i
wonder if everyone else had the same
take as me it's actually a really good
trailer showed a lot of the chaos it's
about to unfold without actually
revealing too much agreed
ah i'm glad i'm not alone yeah this one
says bravo to the team we put this
trailer together pure hype
marvel has that doubt outdone itself
with the trailer i'm sure it's gonna be
one of the best movies come about just
perfect for the role as doctor strange i
do agree he's a very good doctor strange
we can all agree that we should tell him
the truth is multiverse of madness
version of hello peter
that is true
yeah it seems like everybody is uh
is in agreement
love that marvel is getting more and
more ambitious and letting their
directors craft their vision without
getting too in the way
that's probably true because obviously
um
when they were working on everything
leading up to end game i think it's like
a genuine cinematic feat
that
they managed to actually pull everything
off and have
all those characters be introduced and
have people know who they are and follow
the whole plot line and end in a movie
like that like
i don't know that's been done before in
cinema that has to have been really
really hard um and i think they they did
a fantastic job even if like there are
plenty of the marvel movies that i don't
love and they never make my like
favorite movie of the year um it's still
like such a cool ride
and uh
i'm in agreement that it seems like now
that they aren't necessarily as tied to
working towards end game we're getting
some stuff that's like a little bit more
creative and and they're taking some
more risks it feels like which is
awesome
first trailer really held back this
trailer has so much craziness packed
into two minutes can't imagine what the
actual movie will be like literal chills
i agree i had chills
almost the whole time
yeah i'm glad to see other people really
like wanda
literally got chills what a god mode
trailer yeah no i'm i'm glad that uh
every i
think i agree with that like if the
trailer looks that good and there's like
a lot of really exciting action in it
obviously um
but i don't feel like it gave anything
away there's still a lot to be excited
about in the movie
i am
very glad everybody took it the same way
very cool okay let's watch the super
bowl spot shall we okay here is the
version of the multiverse of madness
trailer that aired on
tv during the super bowl
30 seconds let's do it
what do you know about the multiverse
this is probably a rip which is why it
doesn't look as good
you should tell them the truth
it is very totally different
damn
this is like kind of creepy looking
watch the full trailer online
no way that was neat i really i really
appreciate that yeah this is obviously
not in great resolution because it looks
like it's actually probably uploaded by
a third party who i imagine will get in
trouble for uploading it
but i guess we will see um both of those
are awesome let me know what you guys
think i had a great time watching them
yeah a lot to unpack
a lot to think about i'm going to
rewatch them
for sure
i'll see you guys next time bye